[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by aparna Brielle
AKA Tina in Fubar which is out now on
Netflix so make sure you watch the full
season first before this interview
because we're going to be talking some
spoilers here and I mean some serious
spoilers uh aparna first off how you
doing today
um
on cloud nine and I don't I like
everything feels surreal I'm honestly so
thrilled to be here and I'm also so
excited I can finally talk about
spoilers I've been waiting it's been so
hard I'm not gonna it's so hard I'm so
excited yeah so that that's how I'm like
giving like a big big warning because
like you have really the biggest twists
of the Season happening with your
character with Tina in this last episode
and she gets this call and she's like I
can't talk right now I'm middle of
something in Russian so just clear it up
because everyone's gonna want to know
this now like is this not real now is
like is Tina not really into 70 movies
is she a nerd for real is she even into
Barry like what what's going on here is
she even no I think that um I think Tina
does like 70s movies because they're
awesome so I mean like the movies that
she named are all amazing movies but um
yeah I mean
I don't know that I I don't know how to
say what is or isn't real about Tina
because we're still like they're working
the second season out but I do think
that there is a real connection with
Barry I do I think that there is um a
fondness and a kindness and he just has
he's just so open with his heart and
that's not something that Miss Double
Agent Tina has been very exposed to in
her life so I think it's kind of like
suddenly like oh no what do I do with
that I like you oh no right right we're
kind of screwed you know yeah no it's
wild because it throws you for Luke
because we're learning about Tina and
she's in this great like relationship we
get attached to with her and Barry and
then this drops on us
um which is exciting though makes you
look forward to what's gonna happen with
her next and I'm interested too maybe
I'm looking too much into this was there
a little hint early in the season that
something else was going on with Tina
because to me I remember in an earlier
episode she shows up randomly to a
meeting and there's no explanation is
that a hint or is that something I'm
looking away into
um well no I think I mean maybe both
um she she kind of starts out this is
the thing like she she is a young NSA
analyst she is smart and clearly like
good at what she does and she's just
brought on to help early on with the
situation but I think the reason that
you start seeing her showing up more and
more is because this Mission becomes so
like covert and classified that it's on
a need to know basis those people who
have already kind of been involved with
the mission are the only ones they want
involved in so Tina does kind of get
swept up which
I think the Russians were not expecting
and she was not expecting and they're
like oh this is kind of great because
now you're in with like the most senior
level group here tell us what you know
oh that that that's interesting I like
that answer and from an acting
standpoint Did You Know The Twist from
the start and did you play the character
in your head from that angle or was it
easier not even to really think about
that part of her I did know the Twist
from the start I actually knew the twist
when I was going to do the callback or
showrunner told me and then I I was just
sitting there in shock I was like well
how am I supposed to record this now I
need to like process this for a minute
um but she I did I did all of this prep
work and learned all of this stuff and
then I was like I don't want anyone to
be able to tell because I feel like if
you're thinking about it everyone can
read it so I kind of just
threw it all away and um
I I figured when we see the real Tina
come out like the whoever that is
because she's kind of got a million
identities in one
um I feel like when we see that real
person that's where all the elements are
going to come together and um yeah I
just I wanted her to blend in as much as
possible kind of be a low energy version
of me yeah no like let the layers come
come or let the layers get peeled back
for for people to see
yeah no it makes total sense that's
that's a great approach for that I
really like that and did you guys film
most of your scenes in order or was it
kind of out of order your filming
schedule uh it was we it was out of
order for a lot of things especially in
the CIA rooms or you know any of the
cool like office sets we were in we did
do I think largely the episodes were
sort of in order when we shot so I kind
of did get to build into it I did join
in the second episode so like Tina kind
of felt like I got to ease in while
everyone was already in their Zone
um which I really I felt like I had an
advantage there I was like oh you guys
laid it out for me but um yeah by the
time I got to the last thing we shot
actually was the the Russian card game
episode so like that was the very last
thing I shot period and then it was like
4am and then I'm flying home so I
remember like
um it was kind of cool leading up to
that moment although it's not quite the
finale
um because I really got to reveal a lot
there I think yeah and that's I love you
bring that episode up because I
absolutely loved episode six for Tina
and it was very like Casino royale-esque
um no I I want to know though did Tina
have any guilt for poisoning the wrong
guy here and did you feel like you were
in a Bond film on set that day
it did not feel bad bad
um which I kind of I wanted I hoped the
audience might pick up on that a little
bit because she kind of just poisons him
and then like gives like a box off
because I think I wanted that to kind of
be you know this the Russian card game
was interesting because there were other
people showing up like this other
Russian agent that she wasn't expecting
to see there and there are little cracks
in the facade now so I wanted people to
kind of see maybe there is something
not wrong with well maybe there is
something wrong with her and yes I did
feel like I was in a Bond movie I felt
like a Bond girl and it was everything I
wanted it was so much fun I could be on
that set with those people forever yeah
no it was awesome I felt like I could
watch even a whole spin-off show with
you and Barry doing missions like that
which is really cool
um
oh yeah he's great you guys just kill it
together on screen and yeah and there's
more to learn about Tina which I think
was the best part that Revelation at the
end of the season so is there anything
like does it excite you a lot now for
season two and is there anything you
would really like to see like in your
idea of like maybe what could happen
with Tina yeah I'm I'm honestly so so
hyped for season two I have
um I've been told a lot of the ideas
that that they have for Tina and um kind
of the reveals and the things that I get
to do next season including stunts
including you know like really showing
everybody her other personality and like
and like you know my dream situation and
Monica I've talked about this a bunch
but I was I was always hoping for a
little
girl fight where we were fighting
against each other and then there's a
bigger bad maybe and then we both have
to like reluctantly team up please use
this idea I hope
I really like I've begged the show
Runners as many times
but no I really like I think they're
like there's a world of potential with
this character and next season I mean I
got to flex quite a bit at the end of
this one but I think next season we're
really gonna see
so many different layers and I'm I'm
pushing for all of it give me all the
homework I don't mind working extra
hours I feel like it'll be worth it and
so fun
yeah absolutely so everyone again just
watch a partner crush it in Fubar out
now Netflix tell your friends your
family members to watch it's so great
get to watch just kick ass with Arnold
Schwarzenegger what more can you want a
partner thank you so much for joining me
and I hope to talk to you in the future
one day thank you so much this is lovely
bye thank you